and those stories just a moment from now
but first no doubt a lot of you in the
valley watching the smoke and flames
from this a fire at wetlands park that
ted just mentioned
this is in the east valley near sam boyd
stadium yeah the glow of the flames
could be seen for
miles as fire crews raced right to the
scene
sasha loftis is there live near the
nature preserve tonight
with more on the response sasha
denise and brian this fire has already
ripped through about 10
acres of the clark county wetlands park
now you mentioned the glow
you can kind of see that from this
vantage point as that smoke
billows into the air those flames
illuminating it they're
pretty high up in the air you can see
them jump above the trees every once in
a while
as we've been out here for about 15
minutes watching this now this started
around 7 this evening
both the clark county fire department
and the bureau of land management have
been out here working to get this under
control
though it's grown pretty quickly over
the last few hours
the good news no one has been hurt and
the fire hasn't affected any structures
so far
but crews are expected to remain on
scene here through the night
we have seen some clark county fire
trucks drive through this gate here
back and forth as they respond to this
fire now back out here live no word
on a cause just yet but i would avoid
the area for now there are no major road
closures
along this road but you could see some
delays as trucks come
in and out of the area as again they
continue to respond to this fire
through the night and keep it under
control so it doesn't threaten any
structures now
it has died down out here wind wise we
aren't seeing too much wind at the
moment but
i think the real question is how windy
it'll get overnight and how that will
affect the fire out here so we'll go
ahead and send it in to
chief meteorologist ted florendo so ted
what can you tell us sasha thank you
very much yeah winds will continue
overnight and we want to stress that
this is a
live look at that fire from our tower
cam
at sunset station and you could see the
flames right there
see it still burning winds not as strong
as sasha just pinpointed out
but let's look at the winds through the
evening where they were still at double
digits between 10 to 20 miles per hour
that's 6 p.m 7 p.m 8 p.m
still some breezy winds certainly
probably causing some problems for the
firefighters
as it fanned the flames